so last week I did this story where I
admitted that I had been self censoring
on some issues for a while on the
program and I explained it's not for
reasons of monetization it has nothing
to do with that it's because there are
topics that for my mostly left-wing
audience become so toxic and vitriolic
that I question the value in general of
diving into them and I talked about how
I will it became very clear that any
criticism that I would make of any of
the members of the squad for example
would be met with allegations of racism
so I stopped doing those critiques
talking about Venezuela in anything but
glowing terms would get me just slammed
by people on the left in a completely
counterproductive way mentioning Tulsi
Gabbard at all other than to say she's
the best candidate apparently that's the
only thing that's allowed in some
circles and I also mentioned the
israeli-palestinian conflict and the
reaction to the story itself that I did
last week was really positive people
saying they respected me for coming
clean people encouraging me to take on
these topics because the reactions
should and could be respectful and I
want to engage in the battle of ideas
and it's good for the left to figure out
things that we are not United about all
of that stuff so I did and yesterday I
pointed out that I don't think that the
Israeli BDS movement is a force that
will unite the left I don't think it's a
force that will cause change in Israel
or foreign policy I don't believe it has
been effective and in addition I believe
that it hurts people it hurts workers it
hurts small businesses or at least
potentially if it worked although it
hasn't been very effective and really
our gripe is with the right wing
government of Israel so I did that story
yesterday and the reactions to the
segment are now Exhibit A in why I have
been avoiding this and other topics on
the program and it has to do with it
just being unclear that there's an
upside for my sort of audience
demographic for dealing with these
issues it is a talk successful of
comments let's first just start with
some comments from the YouTube channel
which we will put up on the screen for
you some of these have had to be blurred
in some areas in order to maintain FCC
safety Israel is a crime State
committing an ethnic cleansing that's
all that matters f it's fascist
government you are an effing Jew
you can't BS and pretend that's not
relevant it's a little convenient how
you Jews act when it affects Jewish
interests I see you attack whites all
the time over trivial s it doesn't seem
to apply to Jews who do wrong though
that's very obvious f off David you've
exposed yourself as a Zionist shill
crash-and-burn
you stupid effing cuck that's just a
sampling of YouTube comments and then of
course emails which take it up a notch
I'm only putting up a couple of them
there's much more where this came from
but I can't spend the entire day talking
about it David I'd respect you more if
you just said it how it is
greedy Jews want the shekels for
themselves so BSD is bad I guess they
mean BDS you arrogant inian shyster
you'll have it to be more clever to
convince people to oppose BDS so you can
line your pockets like Jews do Wow and
one other Jews should be killed and you
with them you fake shill faux
progressive your entire show exists to
prop up Israel and to destroy the lives
of Palestinians you should be taken off
the air by law or force which is funny
to say that's the goal of the show given
that I've admitted I barely talk about
the issue because it seems so
counterproductive so what is it that is
that issue here it's not can I handle
the emails it's not you know do am i
unable to handle the criticism for what
it is we get 2,000 comments per day and
hundreds of emails and most of them are
negative quite frankly that's not what
this is about the point is is there any
contingent or coalition in our audience
that benefits from me broaching this not
these topics if I do a topic that the
write hates but it unites the left and
it makes us better activists and it
makes us come together and understand an
issue okay there's a reason why it makes
sense to do that
mostly everyone just hates it maybe this
is the wrong lane for my show like is
that a possibility and when I asked that
I don't ask it rhetorically I'm
genuinely coming to you for advice what
do you think the tulsi example is a good
one I mean listen tulsi has been polling
close to zero for a long time if she's
fading out
she's polling 0.8% now or something like
that she'll be out before the September
debates or soon thereafter does it
really make sense for me to do any kind
of critique of Tull C's positions of any
more than it does of John Delaney or
whoever maybe not like maybe it's just
not the right lane for the show that's
my question for you did we really gain
anything in terms of the broader goals
of doing a show like this by me having
done the story that I did yesterday let
me know what you think I I do want to
hear from you